bob newby also known as bob the brain or
bob newbie superhero was born in the
early 1940s in maine he spent much of
his early childhood there until he was a
pre-teen when he moved to hawkins
indiana he attended hawkins middle
school and later hawkins high school
where he developed a crush on a
classmate named joyce byers bob was
likely a social outcast with a keen
ability for solving puzzles and
understanding technology he had a
passion for tech as early as his middle
school years and started a petition and
fundraiser to start the av club at his
school an organization that would last
well beyond his tenure there it's
because of these skills that when radio
shack first opened in hawkins bob became
an employee climbing the ranks to store
manager being originally from maine
being a social outcast and being able to
see patterns and solve puzzles that
others cannot gives bob many common
traits found in the characters from the
stephen king universe bob might even
have a little bit of the shine the
psychic and clairvoyance ability most
prominently featured in stephen king's
the shining to find out how bob could be
a stephen king character stick around to
the end of this video this video is
sponsored by audible
bob wouldn't be the first time stranger
things would exude some inspiration from
stephen king there seem to be
comparisons between 11 and various king
characters most specifically carrie
says she's special
born with abilities
abilities
you're getting a stephen king the
stranger thinks creators the duffer
brothers have made it very clear that
stephen king is a direct inspiration for
much of what they do in an interview
with the emmy awards in 2017 after the
release of stranger things season one
they share what an impact stephen king
had on them and the show
stephen king just i haven't met him in
person but he tweeted about our show and
we've exchanged some emails with him and
that
still blows my mind because he growing
up he was such an inspiration he's like
a god to us and so it's just been
surreal communicating with him at all
it's been amazing but while stephen king
themes are apparent throughout stranger
things bob newby may be in fact the
biggest stephen king nod of them all in
this video i'll be analyzing his entire
story so let's take it back to his
introduction
[Music]
in october 1984 just before halloween
bob appears in the general store and he
asked joyce buyers if they have jack
lantern buckets in any other colors
besides orange he does this to get joyce
alone so they can make out in the stock
room like teenagers this objectively bad
pickup line and their familiarity with
each other makes it clear that they've
been in a romantic relationship for a
little while as they talk in the
storeroom bob expresses that he feels
like a teenager again but that when he
was an actual teenager joyce had no idea
that bob even existed despite them going
to the same school this indicates that
joyce was more popular in high school
and it's hinted that bob might have been
bullied how's uh bob debray
don't call her that sorry old happened
the stereotypes carry over into their
adulthood hopper is the sheriff and bob
is the store manager for radioshack
they're effectively the jock and the
nerd of the real world high school never
ends this would make bob very similar to
the members of the losers club in it as
they are also social outcasts who are
targeted by henry bowers and similar to
carrie from the novel carrie in that
she's a complete outcast who is
tormented by the other students or arnie
cunningham from christine the list goes
on and on bob's excitement about being
with his dream girl from high school
makes it seem like he would have been
very awkward around girls as a teenager
i'm reminded of how the boys are with
beverly marsh from ed's
next stage function high class luncheon
but being an outcast is only the first
trait that makes bob a very stephen king
ask he starts to suggest to joyce that
she should move her family out of
hawkins mentioning that his parents are
thinking of selling their house in maine
the fact that bob's family has a house
in maine means bob probably spent some
of his childhood there many of stephen
king's stories take place in different
parts of maine from its taking place in
the fictional town of derry to the dead
zone set in another fictional town of
castle rock along with many other
stephen king stories so bob probably
grew up in an environment very similar
to that of a lot of stephen king
characters unfortunately joyce rejects
this idea so his parents home in maine
is never mentioned again one morning bob
gives joyce's son will a ride to school
by this point bob knows that will has
gone through something bad but he
doesn't know exactly what he suspects
that will is having nightmares or
something along those lines and offers
guidance by telling a story he describes
meeting a clown at a fair when he was a
kid the clown's name is mr baldo baldo
happens to sound very similar to bozo
who as i mentioned in my horror history
episode on adrian mellon from it was one
of the influences that stephen king
attributes to creating one of his most
iconic monsters anyone even the voice
that bob imitates when describing mr
baldo is very similar to pennywise from
its end at chapter 2.
hey kiddo would you like a balloon
i bet i could cheer him up i'll give him
a balloon but bob's clown imitation is
not the only detail that would make it
seem like bob may have encountered a
creature very similar to pennywise
as a stranger thanks fan you may have
assumed after watching the series
reading the comics and watching my
videos on the show that you would
experience it all but you haven't not
until you've completed the stranger
things officially licensed novels these
stories available on audible detail the
truth behind eleven's mother secrets
about hopper's old life in new york city
robin's sophomore year of high school
and max's life in california as i've
discussed many times on this channel
stranger things with its psychokinetic
heroes and other worldly monsters is
heavily inspired by the works of stephen
king so it's fitting that these
paranormal stories should find their way
into a medium like audible audible
offers an incredible selection of
audiobooks across every genre including
lots of horror if you still can't get
enough stranger things there are also
tons of free podcasts and other viewing
companion pieces audible premium plus
gives you a free title every month or
two if you already have amazon prime and
those titles are yours to keep but
there's also the plus catalog which
gives you access to thousands of titles
that you can just listen to without
spending a credit audible is giving cz's
world viewers 30 days for free cancel
any time just go to
audible.comworld or text easy's world to
500 500. link in description audible.com
cz's world
bob goes on to explain to will that he
couldn't seem to get the clown baldo out
of his head and that every night mr
baldo would come to him in his dreams
this is very similar to how pennywise
would work its way into the dreams and
hallucinations of the seven members of
the losers club one that comes to mind
is ben hanscom's baseball dream he had
finally fallen asleep and dreamed he was
playing baseball with the other boys in
the vacant lot behind tracker brothers
truck depot he had just hit a bases
clearing home run in the dream he was
almost bursting with pride and happiness
and then he had looked out towards
center field where a chain-link fence
marked the boundary between a cindery
lot and the weedy ground beyond that
sloped into the barons a figure was
standing in those tangled weeds and low
bushes almost out of sight it was a
clown when ben awoke the next morning he
had forgotten the dream but his pillow
was damp to the touch as if he had wept
in the night bob shares a lot of
similarities with ben hanscom
specifically ben struggles with his
weight and bob appears to as well
perhaps because of this they both choose
to see themselves as having heroic
qualities while squaring up against
enemies ben chooses to see himself as an
athlete and bob repeatedly refers to
himself as bob newby superhero bob goes
on to describe that baldo kept coming to
him for months until one day the
nightmare suddenly stopped pennywise
only comes out for several months at a
time every 27 years so it would make
sense that this could be pennywise or at
the very least a heavy stranger things
homage to pennywise there are also some
specific details from the stranger
things comic book series that may pay
tribute to stephen king's popular
painted antagonist will tells a story
that occurred in the 1950s about a
tentacled monster referred to as the
child eater of hawkins that shows up
roughly every 20 years and makes kids
disappear in sets of exactly eights
before disappearing again the monster's
pattern is nearly identical to that of
pennywise also the movies on the hawkins
movie theater marquee are showing the
blob and the mummy the mummy was one of
the forms that pennywise took to scare
the members of the losers club and the
blob would certainly fit in with that
too child leader of hawkins is revealed
to have been made up however that
doesn't mean it couldn't have been based
on the urban legends passed down from
the older generation but back to the
conversation with bob and will in the
car bob goes on to explain that he truly
defeated baldo by refusing to run away
anymore
well i fell asleep
and just like always
mr baldo came to me i said go away go
away
just like that
he was gone
never saw him again now i know it
chapter two isn't in the stephen king
canon but i can't help but think about
how the losers club takes their stand
against pennywise by refusing to be
afraid danny torrance in the shining
uses the same tactic to protect himself
from some of the horrors of the overlook
hotel throughout the book in the
follow-up dr sleep the ghost of dick
halloran explains exactly why this
specific technique of standing your
ground and refusing to be afraid can
work for those who have the shine
world's a hungry place
and the darkest things are the hungriest
and they'll eat what shines
swarm it like mosquitoes or leeches
can't do nothing about that
but you can do
turn what they come for against them
this explains why bob standing his
ground and yelling go away repeatedly to
mr baldo would have worked if he had
some shine to him unfortunately this
stand your ground tactic does not work
out for will bob once again exhibits a
potential shine later when he drops by
joyce's house under the impression that
will is sick and offers will some mind
teasers it's here that joyce suddenly
realizes that bob has a unique skill for
solving puzzles and being able to see
what others can't when it comes to
finding solutions she asks him to help
figure out what will's drawings mean of
course not sharing with him that will is
partially possessed by the mind flair
and that these drawings are coming from
that part of will's brain but bob is a
nice guy and goes along with it anyways
sure enough bob is able to see what
others can't
what
what is it i know that shape
it's lover's lake even though joyce
still doesn't fill bob in on what's
going on he goes with them to the
underground tunnels where jim hopper is
trapped and bob participates in saving
it despite the implication that they
never really got along in high school
bob is rushed to the hawkins lab with
joyce will mike wheeler and hopper
rejoice finally fills bob in on what's
been going on leading bob to coin his
own new
nickname i always thought stuff like
this happened in movies and comic books
certainly not in hawkins and certainly
not uh
someone like you
or you yeah
i'm newbie
superhero and that nickname is quickly
puts to test as shortly after this the
creatures known as the demidogs escape
from the upside down and take over the
hawkins lab they're able to knock out
the power stranding bob with hopper mike
joyce will's dr sam owens and an
unconscious will locked away in a safe
room at the upper level of the lab as
hopper risks his life to get to the
basement to turn the breakers back on
bob intervenes with his expert of nerd
knowledge of computer systems he
explains to hopper that turning on the
breakers may restore the power but it
would take an entire reboot of the
system to open the gates so that they
can escape it becomes immediately clear
that the computer programming language
basic is required to do this and bob is
the only one who knows it to further
contrast bob's nerdiness against topper
being the sheriff bob has no idea how to
use a gun requiring hopper to teach him
bob does make it down safely and is able
to restart the breakers and employ his
knowledge of basic to get everything up
and running and open the gates but just
when it seems like he's in the clear the
demi dogs appear on a stairwell on the
computer screen putting both him and
everybody else in danger but once again
bob puts his understanding of basic's
use by putting in the code to start the
fire sprinklers in the stairwell joyce
hopper and the kids make a break for the
exit while dr sam owen stays behind to
guide bob over the intercom to safety
this whole ordeal is very tense bob
brushes shoulders with death several
times sadly for bob just as it seems
like he's in the clear with the demi
dogs trapped and locked out on the other
side of the door like the bumpus dogs on
christmas morning one of them breaks
through like the bumpus's dogs on
christmas morning and bob ends up on the
wrong side of one of the most tragic
deaths that hawkins has yet to endure
but bob's memory perseveres it is
surprisingly mike wheeler who mourns bob
after he's gone and points out that it
was actually bob who originally started
the av club that the kids have been so
active in for the past two years
he petitioned the school to start it and
everything then he had a fundraiser for
equipment
mr clark learned everything from him
pretty awesome right
yeah
we can't let him die in vain bob would
become an unlikely hero for the newest
generation of hawkins middle school
nerds and truly lived up to his
reputation as a classic stephen
king-esque outcast if you want to see
the histories of more stranger boys
click that playlist on the left i've got
more episodes on the way so remember to
subscribe to cz's world for new horrors
every week ring the death bell for
notifications and i'll see you in the
next one assuming we both survive